a lot of people think the thumb
is foundational to um
to the human civilization
um is there any truth to that
i think that is true actually one of the
ways in which the importance of
individual fingers comes
to attention is when people have severe
injuries to their fingers for instance
i have a story in the book about a guy
whose thumb is nearly ripped off by his
dog's leash
and you know when we when plastic
surgeons who are often the ones to
repair that sometimes it's orthopedic
surgeons they will debate you know how
important is it to save this finger or
how important is it to save you know
let's say the kind of
tip uh the one-third the tip one-third
of one of your fingers you know it
depends on the length that you'll lose
it depends on which finger and so the
thumb really is the most crucial um just
you know for your occupation in most
cases to
just daily life um and your ability to
get around take care of yourself and
others so you know they'll be more
they're willing to go further do more
surgeries more aggressive therapy to
save a thumb let's say um than you know
the tip of your pinky finger so in that
way i do think the thumb you know does
seem like the most important in many
ways it's nice that there's backups i
wonder if that's part of the feature or
is it just the symmetry that nature
produces you think you think that two
hands is like is it about the symmetry
or is it about backup we'd be much less
formidable hunters gatherers uh
survivors in any way
if we only had one hand so i think
that is important to have two so we can
you know even everything from kind of
spearing an animal to firing a bow and
arrow to butchering an animal you really
need two hands to do it very effectively
but can you do a better job with three
great question
and we'll never know perhaps
you